le sénat examine le projet de réduction
de la durée du mandat présidentiel
les pouvoirs présidentiels ne peuvent
demeurer longtemps éloigné du peuple dit
monsieur messmer
à l'assemblée nationale incident au
cours de l'examen du projet sur le
commerce et l'artisanat les députés
protestent contre les pressions dont ils
sont l'objet
proche orient très violents combats dans
le sinaï pendant que monsieur kossyguine
est au caire peut-être pour une mission
de paix
l'avion paris-nice détourné sur
marseille par une jeune femme surexcités
sa femme pirate a été tué par la police
le scandale de la garantie foncière
devant la justice 17 inculpé 35 millions
de francs détournés
jean d'ormesson élu au fauteuil de jules
romains à l'académie française est à 48
ans le plus jeune des immortels
le prix nobel de littérature à
l'australien patrick white
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir le sénat donc engagé cet après
midi l'examen public du projet de loi
constitutionnelle réduisant de 7 à 5 ans
le mandat du président de la république
nous vous présenterons en fin de ce
journal le compte rendu complet de cette
discussion est rapidement le point de la
situation au proche orient le caire et
tel aviv sont d'accord pour une fois
pour estimer que de violents et féroce
combat de chars se poursuivent depuis
hier dans le sinaï selon les militaires
américains cette grande bataille
pourrait marquer un tournant décisif de
la guerre du kippour notons d'autre part
que l'egypte et israël ont commencé à
communiquer des listes de prisonniers à
la croix rouge internationale
monsieur kossyguine chef du gouvernement
soviétique est au caire selon le
ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères
c'est une mission de paix qu effectue en
ce moment monsieur kossyguine third
agression a déclaré cet après midi je le
cite on commence à apercevoir un rayon
de lumière des forces puissantes oeuvre
en faveur d'un cessez-le-feu et d'un
règlement à washington on estime même
que monsieur kossyguine s'efforcerait
est actuellement de faire accepter au
caire une formule de cessez-le-feu sur
place le porte-parole de la maison
blanche vient d'annoncer que messieurs
nixon et kissinger espère un arrêt
rapide des combats
mais en attendant les russes serbes
d'antonov 22 pour l'heure point aérien
tandis que les américains utilisent des
galaxies l'avion le plus gros du monde
il transporte cinq chars dans son ventre
hier sur la base américaine des açores
15 galaxy en fait escale mais tous les
avions n'emprunte pas la même route
nombreux sont ceux qui transiterait par
l'allemagne fédérale les deux grands
fournissent aussi munitions et missiles
bref de quoi poursuivre la guerre
générale dyan est d'ailleurs optimiste
il à dit ce soir à la presse
internationale mais des combats sont
durs surtout dans le sinaï le pentagone
affirme que c'est la plus grande
bataille de chars de l'histoire le caire
et tel aviv pour une fois d'accord
qualifie les combats de sang blanc est
féroce toujours sur le front sud le
caire annoncent que les israéliens ont
tenté de s'infiltrer une nouvelle fois
l'année dernière sur la rive occidentale
du canal mais le commando est encerclée
à tel aviv on ne fait aucune allusion à
une nouvelle traversée du canal on
précise en revanche que les égyptiens
auraient perdu aujourd'hui quelque 110
ch à aucune action d'envergure n'aurait
eu lieu aujourd'hui sur le front nord
selon tel aviv pourtant les syriens
démentent il affirme même avoir détruit
sept chars israël
treize jours de la guerre israélo arabe
ne suffisent parmi lesquels il lui
arrivait de communauté juive parce
qu'elles viennent pleurer contre
l'augmentation fruits pour la victoire
des années livret
de l'algérie comme depuis deux
millénaires la selle de la soca y aura
des gardiens villa de lamentations elle
perdit son site né en 1967 qu'ici même
delà de la crise dans l'est une vraie
lire et france le la continuation des
plats quand le stade est
allé largement la star
n'a pas peur même
si
le canada est bien le fric
sa vocation
de précurseur
ainsi
ce nouveau grand soulagement
la triathlète
du camion
sur les grands producteurs pétroliers du
golfe persique le meilleur moyen
d'abattre israël c'est finalement de
frapper les états unis principal allié
de l'état juif comment en fermant le
robinet du pétrole le moment paraît
d'autant mieux choisie que le président
nixon vient d'accorder la priorité au
problème de la pénurie énergétique dont
souffrent les états unis le problème
effectivement presse on l'a vu l'été
dernier avec le rationnement de
l'essence ont les mois à venir ne
s'annonce pas moins difficile si l'on en
croit en tout cas l'un des hommes de
confiance du président l'ancien mise la
défense melvin celui ci vienne conseillé
aux américains de faire provision de
poule aux heures supplémentaires à
défaut de pouvoir se chauffer
convenablement ce tir pourtant de
nombreux experts se refuse à prendre le
boycott aux séries d'abord distille le
moyen-orient n'assure que 5 % des
approvisionnements amérique ensuite pour
être efficace la réduction de la
production décidées à koweït devra selon
eux avoir les mêmes conséquences pour
tous les consommateurs car sinon les
états unis pourront toujours acheter les
surplus européen au japon ville
washington les arabes risquent pas leur
de s'aliéner des pays pourtant acquis
alors et puis à quelque chose malheur
est bon disent les experts le boycott
peut même être sa lutte et en obligeant
l'amérique à moins gaspiller en incitant
le gouvernement à se lancer dans un
effort sérieux pour développer d'autres
ressources énergétiques les raisins sans
trop vers quoi qu'il en soit à
washington on s'inquiéterait plutôt des
dangers que les pays pétroliers
pourraient faire courir un dollar déjà
bien fatigué
une menace qui semble réel après
l'annonce que les arabes pourraient
convertir en marque ou un yen leurs
avoirs en dollars
or si les quatre grands du golfe
persique compte encaissé l'an dernier 5
milliards de dollars en 1980 l'arabie
saoudite le koweït abu dhabi et qatar
disposeront de revenus annuels 5 ou 6
fois supérieure à ce moment là rien
n'empêchera théoriquement les émirs
pétrolier de s'acheter des secteurs
entiers de l'économie numérique
le pétrole arme ultime
pour la maison blanche boycott ou pas
c'est encore la politique fixée
à beyrouth la guerre du proche orient
n'a pas arrêté le terrorisme pro
palestiniens on n'est pourtant pas
encore certain que les cinq hommes
qu'ils retiennent en otage des clients
de la bank of america de beyrouth depuis
ce matin donc des mobiles politiques ils
réclament une rançon de 10 millions de
dollars la libération de 12 de leurs
camarades d'un mouvement révolutionnaire
et de tous les palestiniens incarcérés
au liban une trentaine de personnes sont
aux mains du commando celui ci menace de
les exécuter s'il n'obtient pas
satisfaction la police utilise sans
résultat des bombes lacrymogènes
le commando est bien armé cinq personnes
auraient été blessées par des coups de
feu tirés au moment de l' attaque de
l'immeuble
ce n'est pas la loi elle-même qui l'a
provoqué c'est l'occupation des chambres
de commerce et d'industrie par des
militants du cidunati et les pressions
directes faites sur les députés coup de
téléphone nocturne façades d'immeubles
maculés de peinture et ce matin encore
par aso péniche devant le palais bourbon
à 15 heures au moment de la reprise du
débat monsieur michel debré eu des airs
dénonçait le premier je cite les
méthodes fascistes ainsi employés et
demander la remise à quinzaine l'examen
du projet après lui onze députés
représentant les différents groupes de
l'assemblée demandé une suspension de
séance soulignant que les pressions qui
s'exercent sur le parlement
n'empêcheront pas les députés de voter
selon leur conscience
après que le ministre monsieur royer et
déclaré que le gouvernement s'élèvent
contre toutes les pressions et violence
la séance était suspendu ce n'est donc
peu avant 18 heures que les députés ont
repris l'examen du projet de loi sur le
commerce et l'artisanat
mais ce n'est que demain ils reparlerons
de l'article qui a provoqué les remous
que l'on sait la représentation des
commerçants et artisans au sein des
commissions qui seront chargés de
t'autorise et la création de grandes
surfaces ici
c'est la foule devant la 17e chambre
correctionnelle de paris en vue
d'accueillir tout le monde le parquet a
renoncé finalement à la 11e chambre plus
exigu mais il n'a pas vu encore assez
grand une bonne trentaine d'avocats
accompagne les dix-sept prévenus de ce
scandale financier faute de place
l'ancien député yves henry et mettre aux
roches noires qui était le conseiller
fiscal de la garantie foncière ont dû
s'installer sur les bancs du public
n'allez pas croire pour autant que les
débats ont pris le ton aimable d'une
conversation de salon au contraire
d'entrée la défense la partie civile et
le ministère public ont engagé une
véritable bataille juridique qui
semblent voler au dessus de bien des
têtes on en retiendra si possible
l'essentiel les avocats de la défense
s'efforce de faire constater une série
de nullités de procédure ou si vous
préférez que l'instruction a été entaché
d'irrégularités inacceptable ainsi
maître victor du bois un des avocats de
son confrère roches noires que vous
allez voir dans un instant à droite à
son arrivée au palais affirme que
l'inculpation de son client et la
perquisition à son cabinet en outre 71
constitue une violation des droits de la
défense selon maître dubois on a saisi
sans discernement 3500 pièce au cabinet
roches noires y compris la
correspondance de l'avocat avec ses
clients la partie civile qui représente
les quelques milliers de souscripteurs
de la garantie foncière n'est pas en
reste m da frais soutenant que des
rapports de police ont été escamotées
veut renvoyer la sphère en cour
d'assises bref avec ses querelles de
procédure pénale le véritable procès de
la garantie foncière n'est toujours pas
ouvert et on en a presque oublié cet
après midi les principaux acteurs les
prévenus parmi eux robert frank l
l'animateur de la garantie foncière en
prison depuis juillet 71 est un peu plus
pâle que les autres ils échangent
quelques mots de temps à autre avec sa
femme nicole inculpée elle aussi
d'escroquerie mais en liberté pourrait
également les choses sérieuses n'ont pas
encore commencé
allégement de l'impôt en 1973 pour les
petits contribuables c'est selon maurice
papon rapporteur général du budget et
invité aujourd'hui des journalistes de
la presse économique et financière
la première conséquence de l'amendement
de justice fiscale déposées par le
gouvernement reste une difficulté
l'organisation de la compensation
nationale ont fait effectivement
supportés par certains régimes le
déficit d'autres régimes je pense que
c'est une difficulté qui pourra être
surmontée je l'espère en tout cas pas
bon parce que l'objectif de la
solidarité sociale ne peut effectivement
que réunir l'assentiment de tous
il est 12h 10 lorsque l'avion paris nice
un boeing 727 et détourné sur l'aéroport
de marseille marignane 110 passagers
sont à bord l'une des passagères une
jeune femme de 35 ans épouse d'un
publiciste parisien armé d'une carabine
22 long rifle menace soudain une hôtesse
de l'air elle semble agité et tient des
propos incohérents
ces exigences sont confuses l'avion se
pose à marignane à 12h30 la passagère
exprime alors le désir de manger peu
après trois policiers déguisés montent
dans l'avion la jeune femme les met en
joue et policiers font peu l'abaissant
mortellement un steward raconte
la poussière le chef de cabine il a
d'ailleurs confié il est encore sous le
coup d'une certaine émotion
au départ manifesté juste avec un
pistolet nous avons eu par la suite
qu'il devait être un pistolet remet à
blanc ensuite une carabine qu'il a
téléchargé avec un gain de sécurité
ensuite je pense que la sortie à
deuxième pistolet mais vous savez du
moment sont assez longs
et bien et passer par la finlande près
ce que j'en sais la banque dbs hippie et
cette carabine se trouvait dans un sac
où tout était son chien mais
quinze mille litres de kérosène pour
partir
elle voulait se poser dans des régions a
eu dix ans parce qu'on ne comprenais pas
où elle voulait vraiment aller on lui a
en a emmené le camion d'essence vous
avez vu et puis elle a demandé à manger
à ce moment là trois hommes de mon gip
du groupe d'intervention de la police se
sont déguisés en soirée un mécanicien et
ont pu pénétrer dans l'avion mais
subitement elle a mis en joue le
mécanicien un deuxième homme était
mécanicien j'ai eu le réflexe
immédiatement dégainé et se tirer la
blessant gravement lire et légitime
défense ah oui parce que l'homme a été
mis en joue et y avait la vie de chou et
de stewards il n'y a que trois hommes
qui sont montés trois hommes et trois
hommes puis-je de tower qui était sur un
siège elle d'ailleurs c'était très bien
placé elle était je sais pas si vous
connaissez l'intérieur d'un
ring elle était entre les deux voies à
terre les deux waters du fond du bowling
et elle recommandait est en vraiment
entre ces deux batteurs l'augmenter
toute l'allée des sièges qui vous vient
ce qui fait que n'importe qui qui se
présentaient à d'avant été immédiatement
une cible facile on a pu voir était un
maître d'elle on a vu des hommes montés
par l'arrivée des hommes sont montés par
ailleurs quand le mécanicien a pu tirer
qui est jean d'ormesson le plus jeune
des académiciens il n'a que 48 ans et 10
une grande famille française qui compte
à un chancelier de france 2 contre leurs
généraux des finances onze conseillers
d'état et quatre ambassadeurs de france
dont son père et son oncle wladimir
d'ormesson récemment décédé qui était
également membre de l'illustre assemblée
mais c'est bien sur ces titres
littéraire qu'en 1971 l'académie
française lui accorder le grand prix du
roman pour la gloire de l'empiré a pris
barak coup de téléphone que j'attendais
évidemment et c'est une certaine émotion
et le sentiment que j'éprouve amy a
lancé vous imaginez bien de une grande
joie et beaucoup de gratitude
vous vous attendiez cette nouvelle je
l'espérais et vous savez quoi tient une
élection on ne peut jamais être
certain du résultat
qu'est ce qui d'après vous a pu inciter
le suffrage dans ce sens qu'elles ont
demandé dans la durance
l'indulgence pour 60% et puis pour 25%
l'amitié et puis peut-être pour 5% mais
mérite
quelles actions pensez-vous avoir au
sein de l'académie en tant que benjamin
de cette académie et viens d'écouter
beaucoup d'être très assidus comme un
volet collier et puis de taches et
d'apprendre et puis on verra après
le prix nobel de littérature a été
décerné aujourd'hui à patrick white pour
un large c'est l'académie suédoise pour
un arrêt pique et psychologiques qui a
introduit une nouvelle partie du monde
dans la littérature en effet patrick
white 61 ans auteur de sept romans dont
deux traduits en français est le premier
australien lauréat du prix nobel le
dernier nobel de langue anglaise et l
américain john steinbeck il y à onze ans
de cela
discussion donc cet après midi au sénat
du projet de réduction du mandat
présidentiel
l'hémicycle était comble les divers
orateurs sont intervenus dans le plus
grand calme on pense que le vote aura
lieu cette nuit rendons-nous et senna
la sérénité sénatoriale n'a pas été
entamée cet après midi par le débat
constitutionnel s'il y eu quelques
mouvements de séance notamment lorsque
monsieur dailly et monsieur pierre
messmer évoquèrent les pouvoirs du
président de la république pour l'un son
jugement sur la durée du mandat pour
l'autre ces mouvements ne dépassera pas
le stade des murmures sur les bancs de
la gauche le sénat est donc resté cette
haute assemblée où la passion n'a pas sa
place et où les débats se font certes
avec fermeté mais toujours avec
courtoisie même l' alerte à la bombe du
début de l'après midi n'a pas modifié le
climat une séance donc intéressante où
l'on a débattu en profondeur de cette
réforme ce qu'il faut en retenir c'est
que le sénat n'a pas l'intention d'être
le fossoyeur du texte proposé mais il
n'a pas l'intention non plus d'en être
le défenseur inconditionnel pour une
grande partie s'est aussi dans les
couloirs que se déroulait le débat
journaliste sénateurs et membres des
cabinets ministériels s'y livrer au jeu
subtil des pronostics le sénat votera
t-il le texte et avec quelle majorité on
peut hasarder à un pronostic les
sénateurs devraient voter le texte ce
soir et vraisemblablement sans
amendement comme à l'assemblée nationale
il n'y aurait donc pas de navette il y
aura certes en séance de nuit des
discussions sur des amendements sur une
dizaine d'amendements proposés mais la
plupart mais il devrait être nokia
devrait être retenue par don cela dit
les votes favorables
passeront-ils le cap des trois
cinquièmes des suffrages exprimés ces
fameux trois cinquièmes qu'il faut au
congrès pour que le texte soit ratifié
c'est là de la politique fiction à
laquelle je me refuse pour ma part de me
livrer je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter des extraits du débat de cet
après midi
kir a expliqué au bon sens populaire à
moins bien sûr de lui faire voter sur la
vie chère sur les encombrements la
mauvaise qualité des transports et aux
ce que nous avons toujours combattu
c'est pour ça que nous avons toujours
combattu les référendums dans cette
maison mais qui a expliqué au bon sens
populaire à moins de le faire voter sur
autre chaude et par conséquent de le
dévier sur autre chose qu'il est
contraire à la démocratie de revenir lui
rendre tous les cinq ans
conques
s'évanouir si on ne veut pas
surreprésentés au contraire briguer à
nouveau les suffrages des électeurs
tels sont les motifs pour lesquels
s'en tenant aux textes aux textes seuls
sache voulant ignorer les commentaires
et l'environnement nous l'étudions que
pour ce qu'il contient et que pour ce
qu'il dit et n'ayant pour seul souci que
le prestige de notre assemblée
votre commission vous demande
d'approuver sans amendements le texte
qui vous est soumis
si le septennat pouvait se concevoir et
a pu se maintenir
avec une élection
venant d'un collège électoral limitée
est dans un système où l'essentiel des
responsabilités nationales
échappé au président de la république
il paraît plus difficile
il paraît très difficile même d'en
justifier l'existence dès lors que le
président est élu par tous les citoyens
et qu'il assume les plus grandes
responsabilités nationales
l'expérience nous dit le président de la
république l'a convaincu de donner sa
préférence
à un mandat de cinq ans
et sur ce point mesdames et messieurs et
sénateurs
je souhaite vous rendre particulièrement
attentes
qui mieux que le président de la
république
connaît toutes les données du problème
que nous débattons
proposé de réduire la durée du mandat
présidentiel
est une décision grave
si monsieur georges pompidou le propose
après avoir pratiqué les responsabilités
qui sont les siennes et cela depuis plus
de quatre ans c'est parce qu'il a porté
en conscience un jugement sur leur
exercice
il serait regrettable je le dis
sincèrement
que sur un texte qui ne soulève pas de
critique essentielle de critiques
fondamentales
la voie parlementaire de l'article 89
conduisent à un échec ne peut-on
craindre si tel était le cas que cela
porte atteinte à la valeur de cette
pratique institutionnelle
si vous votez ce texte
vous montrerez madame et messieurs et
sénateurs que vous partagez le souci qui
anime le gouvernement
assurer l'organisation de nos pouvoirs
publics
c'est à dire une organisation qui
intéresse le parlement tout autant que
le gouvernement et qui attirait ce pays
tout entier assurer cette organisation
par un ensemble de règles vivante
moderne
c'est-à-dire
appropriés en fin de compte au
gouvernement de la france de demain
ne vaut-il pas mieux les risques offert
par un retour plus fréquents du
président devant les électeurs pour
légitimer son action
fut notre consultation sur un quelconque
sujet futile importants par la voie
référendaire de l'article 11 dont
l'objet serait fou c est qui
provoquerait sans doute à nouveau
renouer critique
une telle révision ne peut naître ne
peut être menée à bien qu'avec le
concours du gouvernement
votre accord public monsieur le premier
ministre ne parle pas d'engagement je ne
me permettrais pas de parler
d'engagement sera la promesse du premier
ministre mais aussi celle de monsieur
pierre mais ce père qui a le grand
privilège de bénéficier de la confiance
personnelle de nombreux membres du
parlement mais aussi de très nombreux
français cette aile et emportera pour
une large part
notre adhésion au projet de révision
constitutionnelle
en réduisant les délais
qui sépare les consultations
présidentielles
ont fait progresser plus profondément un
instant où ceux ci a toute son
importance les règles de la démocratie
ainsi il sera possible de mieux tenir
compte des événements des
transformations rapides de la société et
de ne jamais laisser un désaccord
fondamental
s'établir entre l'opinion publique et le
chef de l'état en résumé les chapeaux
laghi nous est proposée par la voie
parlementaire une réforme à la fois
simple et importante correspondant à la
réalité de notre temps et de la vie
politique moderne attribuant aux
citoyens des droits nouveaux et des
responsabilités accrues
dans une démocratie le peuple reste
toujours larbitre suprême de la volonté
nationale
alors n'est-il pas dans le sens de
l'histoire de rapprocher le temps de ces
sentences
cinq ans s'étend et bien oui à priori
a priori je pense que en effet il est
peut-être préférable
que le mandat présidentiel soit limité à
5,1
alors
je serais tenter de vous dire bon balle
je vais laisser passer de cette
modification
mais à la condition que rien ne soit ni
en dehors de la modification de chiffres
mais le vrai problème de sur premier
ministre c'est qu'en réalité vous n'avez
jamais
trouvé le moyen de résoudre le conflit
qui peut arriver excusez moi dont j'ai
souhaité qu'il arriva à savoir une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale
fondamentalement différente des options
du brizola et public alors
se soumettent ouzou met ou se démettre
alors là non je n'ai pas convenant
en votant le texte dès 5 ans l'ombre
pour l'accompagnement pour
l'environnement pour les maris fication
des fonctions que le président de la
république
que le président de la république doit
s'arroger c'est à dire la disparition du
gouvernement nous aurons certes encore
nominalement nommément des ministres
il s'appelle rompent que toujours
ministre ils seront sans aucun doute des
animateurs ils seront très certainement
des exécutants ils seront des organes de
propagande visas visent la population
irlandaise organe de liaison vis-à-vis
des assemblées et au lieu d'avoir un
secrétaire d'état pour les relations
avec le parlement le jour où une
quinzaine de ministres mais nous
retenons surtout que le gouvernement
serein alors le porte parole du goût un
haut lieu des trains de pouvoir
apprécier ce texte qui nous est proposé
ce serait admettre que le rôle
d'arbitrage évolué au président de la
république par l'article 5 de la
constitution ne rime plus à rien et que
le président est le véritable chef de
l'exécutif faute et le quinquennat je
serai pas croire autorité personnelle du
président de la république au détriment
du peu de pouvoir qui reste au parlement
ce serait accentué le cracpe et le
caractère présidentiel du pouvoir sans
lui apporter le moindre con froid voter
le quinquennat ce serait du même coup
accepté le considérer comme caduc
l'article 20 de la constitution
stipulant que le gouvernement est
responsable devant le parlement ce
serait en définitive bien filer
allègrement à la constitution à la
demande de celui qui est chargé
d'assurer le respect
après matthieu duclos on a entendu trois
orateurs monsieur legaret république
indépendant il ne se prononcera que ce
soir après avoir entendu de nouveau le
premier ministre monsieur pelletier
gauche démocratique a annoncé qu'il
voterait contre le projet quant à
monsieur fréville union centriste il a
donné un oui conditionnel sous réserve
que le premier ministre réponde
favorablement un toilettage plus complet
de la constitution et une collaboration
plus étroite entre le parlement et le
gouvernement la discussion reprend à 22
heures le vote tard dans la nuit je vous
retrouve pour ma part à 24 heures
dernier
d'autres détails donc sur cette
discussion au sénat à 24 heures dernière
vers 23h15 l'agent souhaitèrent confirme
dans une dépêche datée du caire que des
pourparlers sur un éventuel cessez le
feu au proche orient se déroule entre le
président anouar el-sadate et monsieur
kossyguine sur l'incident sur son et
vous souhaite de passer une excellente
soirée car ça